travis scott will reportedly not perform
at this weekend's day in vegas festival
and will provide full refunds to all
attendees who bought tickets to
astroworld i just want to send out
prayers to the
to the ones that was lost i could just
never imagine the severity of the
situation according to variety the
rapper was scheduled to headline at the
las vegas festival grounds on saturday
november 13th less than a week after his
own astroworld festival in houston where
eight attendees died and hundreds of
others were injured
[Applause]
but according to the outlet sources
travis is quote too distraught to play
and we'll be refunding all astro world
ticket holders there's this very unique
kind of
exchange of energy between him and the
crowd he amps up the crowd absolutely
but it's almost like they amp him up as
well it's it's like a back and forth as
a concert goer in the moment you know
you're full of adrenaline you know your
your emotions are up here it you know
you do things or feel things you know in
a very heightened state on monday et
spoke to the houston chronicle music
critic who was at the show it was very
apparent that he saw some incidents
happening during this show he would stop
a song and start it over
because someone was injured or he saw
them in distress and he wouldn't just
stop and point it out he would wait
until security got there helped that
person took them out i think he was
really doing
what he thought he was supposed to
there's no way he knew
kind of the enormity of what was
happening
[Music]
on saturday travis spoke out for the
first time following the tragedy
breaking down in tears on instagram my
fans really mean the world to me we're
actually working right now
to identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time at the festival on friday
night travis brought the show to a halt
more than once
as it became apparent something had gone
very wrong in the crowd you know i just
stopped the show and
you know help them get the help they
need you know
i could just never imagine this
irradiated situation we've been working
closely
uh we've been working closely with
everyone to just try to get to the
bottom of this city houston hpd
fire department
you know everyone uh
you know help us
help us figure this out travis ended his
message with a personal promise i'm
gonna do everything i can to keep you
guys updated and
just keep you guys
informed on what's going on love you all
meanwhile houston law enforcement spoke
out on friday night announcing the start
of what's expected to be a major
investigation what the event promoters
had established for for the event they
did have a medical component they did
have some transport units
but uh
of course they were they were quickly
overwhelmed over 300
patients were treated at the at the
field hospital that was out that was set
up out here at this at this location